[Music]
andy is on the line in atlanta georgia
andy welcome to the ramsay show
thank you very much i'm a huge fan and a
follower of dave's
steps uh for many years since i
a while back quit my job to gain
ownership in the business and took like
a 75 pay cut for a while so wow the
envelope system got us through awesome
cool to hear how can we help today
well
so
i went through that period of time to
gain ownership in a business
i've been able to turn the business
around and grow it relatively
significantly
so i'm no longer at the 75 percent pay
cut level and
i've been a lifelong favor
we're debt-free have been for years
house has paid off
uh
we could
technically retire
if we needed to i'm 54.
but anyway we're to a point where i mean
our kids college is all fun that i met
two in college and i'm wondering at what
point is it okay
to or how do you get over the guilt when
you want to buy yourself a toy
i've never done it i've always put the
money in the bank i've always saved it
i've always
been the responsible one but darn it i
want a mid-engine corvette
there we go
say it out loud andy so you guys have
been so diligent for so long that now
you're like i can't seem to let go of
this money even though i saved i worked
so hard it just feels frivolous i love
how andy said how do you get over the
guilt i was like what guilt andy
where is the skills coming i'm the
spender andy the fact that you said that
shows that you're just such a saver
which is what's led to your success
today so well done yeah well you know
thank you what helps me is is taking
some of the emotion out of it taking the
guilt out and just looking at hard
numbers and we've got some parameters to
help you you know make a wise decision
here so what is your annual income
well all right i'll say it varies but
it's going to be between 275 and 350.
wow
fantastic and how much does this car uh
cost
uh about 85 out the door
okay
and do you have any other uh vehicles
right now anything with a motor in it
boats any other toys yeah uh one other
vehicle we actually just uh
gave our senior in college our older car
for uh
for his great success in college so
we're down to one
uh
kia that we paid cash for wow what's
that kia worth
oh probably about 20 grand
okay
so if you got this 85 grand corvette
that leaves you with about 105 000
worth of cars and that's it nothing else
with motors in it
and you make up to 350 thousand dollars
a year
yes
andy uh it's an easy decision for me
now but now you know the answer the
answer is yes you can buy the car but
the real question is how do i get over
the guilt about buying this car well the
other thing is and
believe me i went over the numbers with
my my wife because we just i just did
the profit sharing for the business and
i mean that alone pays for the car but
i so i did this
with my wife on my life if you think i'm
a saver
you ought to see my wife she's a bigger
saver so well yeah our our general
purpose
she's on board but okay she's on board
our parameter is that we don't want more
than 50 of your income tied up and
things with motors in it because they go
down in value and so sometimes it helps
to look at this from a give save spend
perspective
if you want to make this a more wise
decision make you feel better about it
go ahead and give a portion of that
profit sharing and be generous with it
and then you'll feel a little more free
to spend some of it and you already have
plenty of savings it sounds like you
guys can retire early you've done so
well now is the time to enjoy this stuff
a lot of people they go through life and
they work so hard their fists are closed
they're just clenched working their
whole lives and you guys have earned
this this is not a frivolous purchase
now if you were calling me and you were
a 22 year old who had student loan debt
and said hey i want to buy an 85 000
corvette i'd smack him upside the head
but andy i want to give you a high five
and take a ride in that thing that's
right
here's the other thing andy and i if
you're like my husband and how he's
wired he's the saver in our relationship
and and he hates spending money like
even if we have the money even if we
budgeted we're on the same page it's
something we want we need whatever i
remember we moved in our house and we
wanted to get a tv for the bonus room
and he wanted to get this big
flat screen tv we absolutely had the
money we budget he still was like torn
up but
after we got it he loved watching
football games on this tv i think you're
gonna love having it this is something
you want you've worked really hard your
whole life to save and be wise you're
debt free your home is paid for you have
an incredible income
yes
yes you can enjoy some of it and that's
part of it so maybe for you because
you're such a saver andy maybe you start
to think anticipate the reward
anticipate man this can be so fun to
have and to your point george
uh you have worked for it andy you have
worked for it you have earned it and uh
you should enjoy some of the fruits of
your labor some of the fruits of your
hard work way to go inspiring stuff that
is so cool it's so funny how different
people are wired differently
of the sabers and the spenders the
savers even if they have the money they
struggle to spend it the spenders even
if they have the budget budget they
struggle to save so it's just it's in
our wiring but hey it's what it's what
he values and he's worked really hard
for so cool we love to see it